it is hard somehow to see the beginnings
of an economic unravelling the
nervousness people feel as to what may
happen to their cash
the memories it stirs from an era they
thought was behind them
chris is i remember the crisis of 1998
when we woke up and one dollar cost six
rubles and the next morning it was 24.
i'm coming to take out the last penny if
i see it
state tv did its best to pass on a
reassuring message the central bank too
more than doubling interest rates to 20
with assurances that the banking system
was stable
all the funds in clients account are
preserved and all transactions are
available to clients
president putin held an emergency
meeting to discuss the sanctions his top
advisers crammed around one end of a
long table the man who appears more and
more to be the lone decision maker at
the other
yep
i invited you to talk about questions
related to economy and finance
talking about those sanctions which the
so-called western community as i called
it in my speech an empire of lies tries
to realize against our country
but this heralds the start of dark times
for the russian people putin's long
trumpeted claim that he brought this
country stability after the chaos of the
1990s now not so clear-cut
the history of the last 20 years
was rewritten in the last five days and
economically it's the same you cannot
say that putin bring brought russia to a
different point of stability or
prosperity okay that's gone
and the western community that so-called
empire of lies might have more sanctions
up its sleeve yet russia's central bank
now reeling from the punches
quite the day they've been having in
there and this is probably just the
start of it russia would always point to
its huge foreign reserves as a great
bulwark against sanctions but with a
large chunk of those foreign reserves
held in g7 countries it means the
central bank now can't sell them to prop
up the ruble which seems to be a huge
flaw at the heart of putin's
counter-sanction strategy
the west always made clear they would
unleash sanctions hell should vladimir
putin invade ukraine now as ukrainians
face an immediate and existential threat
from their brother nation next door back
home the russian people too will find
themselves paying for a long long time
to come
in magnay sky news moscow